evan bliss
well here we are again do you believe it
i'm so pumped
i think this one's gonna be one for the
ages
i think so too i'm like
so happy and joyful about it well
and
it's excellent that it's happening
with you yeah
this guy knows how to flatter i'll tell
you that
i think we're both a little blissed out
this i was telling alan earlier this
the fire plus this lighting it just
feels like you're in a sun
sun cave or something yeah there's kind
of an
odd oxymoron a sun cave caves are
usually dark but
beside the point yeah
and most of that bliss
that we speak of
comes from unknowing
sure it comes from a knowing
is
indescribable and ineffable as
lao tza says that the tao that can be
named is not the eternal dao
yet as we
have dialectic about the nature of our
existence as we sort of pierce
the veil of our
selves who we truly are
why we are here
it becomes more and more of a natural
state
of being is that bliss
that sure peace that
love that compassion that wisdom
that quote being high on life
and so one of the things that we wanted
to do
in this conversation was sort of provide
a more
common
facing dialectic so something that was a
little bit more relatable
a little bit more we want to
make this portal that we're creating
with the show
we want to make it a little bit more
efficacious
efficient with people to be able to jump
through
and to see kind of what we're talking
about so
one of the best places to start is
really asking yourself the
perennial question
the one that's plastered around
all of the ancient spiritual
traditions
what is i
what is me
what is that
and if we begin
down that path of what is the i
what is the nature of our existence
and what is the nature of even just
the simple fact of being
aware then
it usually leads
people down paths of investigation
to where they get to sort of what we
were talking about
a moment ago
one of the first things that usually
comes
on that path is
the the realization
of the
we're going to create a juxtaposition
and
hopefully that juxtaposition
will be helpful for people but
ultimately it is one so we are
separating into two
as evan pointed out before we went live
to create
contrast in order for people to
slowly baby step
towards this or if you want to
as siddhar mishwar said you can birdsway
yourself to this
these realizations
so the juxtaposition is
as simple as
we're going to use the word coloration
to describe
thoughts feelings
emotions objects
and that's coloration of your awareness
of your consciousness of your sentience
and then what is awareness or
consciousness or sentience
without coloration
and so by creating that juxtaposition
and sort of like
working out a muscle
you're basically over time
becoming more and more aware
of awareness without coloration
is that making sense
yeah yeah um
i think there's a meta element to this
like
because granted i think
as we said before we started this we
want this to kind of go where it goes
um but i think we probably since we both
had this topic in the back of our minds
for a few weeks since we first kind of
discussed
the idea of centering something around
this i think both of our brains have
probably deliberated on this topic
and yeah i think almost the meta side of
what you just said is
is i think what we were
thinking that this conversation could be
about is almost
or i guess through my reading was i mean
i think it can be
a meditation but i think there's almost
a directness and a specificity as well
that
the thesis i had in mind was almost how
do analytical people
like us how do people that are whose
first impulse is to take a
scientific analytical point of view on
examining life events
or oneself how do you get in touch
with the feeling aspect yeah this this
idea that
rationality has a
um that there that there is the notion
that rationality
can't solve everything right or doesn't
have all the answers
you know that and i think there is a
tendency if you're that type of person
you know that really um
would you say really respects and
glorifies rationality which is such a
powerful tool
that you don't want to get it's it's one
must be careful not to get so drunk on
rationality that they don't
that they can't see the things bubbling
up inside themselves which
which i think we were losing
maybe that's probably the coloration and
to use your terminology yeah yeah i mean
and you know i don't know a way to
and some of this is is
i can only make assumptions about how
your audience
what they're like or what they're not
like and i would think that based off
generally the kind of talks you have on
your channel that they probably are more
analytical
science interested folks so i mean
perhaps there is some practical utility
and
can we i'm not saying we we were
going to solve this kind of idea of
helping them get in touch with their
feelings in one day but
maybe even just saying that maybe just
positing that as an idea is enough
you know kind of this idea that
and i think this is a go ahead this is a
good place
when evan brings up the
notion of becoming
more in touch with a
an integral or a holistic
approach to your being
that includes not only the
analytical rational scientific
but includes this sort of feeling
emotional
body oriented
approach yeah that's a great actually
that's a really good way to put it
it is very much centered in the body and
i
you know and this is sort of anecdotal
but i think if you were to observe
your average nerd if you will right like
there's a reason why we associate
body awkwardness with nerds right it's
because everything's up here
like they're not they haven't made peace
and made
um they don't understand their
connection between the mind and the body
right or they haven't fleshed that out
they've yet to
to flesh that out in their
way of being right um very much like
this you know what i mean
graphic from the high level perception
chapter 9 on
identity because
it is very much like having a red box
around your head and living in your head
and living in a completely
cut off separate not only from
your own body not only from your own
body
which is where most people run into the
situation of like
when you have a signal coming from your
body
of like bruh like your knees right now
or your lower back
right now like get up and go
stretch in the sun for 10 minutes
yep like okay so
if you're not in tune with that
you uh that's already some place to
become more in tune so yeah that
is a good starting point and then an
example on the left is sort of the next
level which is beyond just having the
interconnection of
the body which there we reference a lot
with sort of the
the respiration and the water
and the food and the microbiome sure but
also the relationship that
that has that
individual has in a more perforated
sort of way like their entire being is
more perforated
and so that way explain that it's more
porous
okay so it's more porous the the
individual is much more
porous in its understanding that
that inhale came from the photosynthesis
of phytoplankton and trees and so
i'm more aware of that depth of
interconnection how literally the planet
is sustaining my life and so
now we're at a whole nother level where
it's not just
i'm becoming aware of my individual body
but i'm becoming aware of the entire
planet's aliveness the entire planet's
unity the entire planet's
interconnectivity
and so then at that point like the
oceanic-ness
of the planet at that point
that's where we become sort of
next level so we can let's stay at sort
of the lower
level for now which is what you were
indicating which is sort of moving
one's attention uh
from you know again just thinking about
it like
like a hole in the hole
if you're only taking the perspective of
the analytical
and the rational then you're missing
simultaneously
right because you want to simultaneously
be able to hold
the feeling and the emotional and the
body
perspective the heart perspective the
gut perspective
while you hold the brain cutting
everything up
chopping it all up scientifically
validating it
i have it actually really interesting
and really like to the point thing to
say here like perfect
i think what's interesting about this is
the analytical
the the physical and the oceanic
physical
almost represent three archetypes right
like um if you take those things through
their most stereotypical
the analytical is like the geek that's
sitting in the back of the class that
is scrolling all these brilliant notes
like can't keep his glasses on his face
because he's like so
physically unaware of his body mechanism
and if you take that's to its highest
impetus that's not a complete picture
because all those ideas will live and
die with that person because he lacks
he's not grounded in the physical enough
to to propagate those ideas right
like they never leave his mind they
never live this part
because they haven't transferred
themselves out through the body
archetype number two
is somebody who's super in the body is
is the joke is the
hollywood version of the dumb jock right
like they're so grounded in their body
they're so grounded in their bodies so
good at catching that pass it at like
doing that bicep curl it just you know
feeling that central energy around women
you know this kind of
very much of the physical but that's a
beauty too because you're speaking the
native language of animals and of humans
and you need that you need that in your
arsenal
but if you take that to its extreme it's
it has no brain right it has no
analytical it has no philosophical
it's devoid it's so embodied that it's
it's
it has no further potential beyond just
that one vessel it's very singular
and then i would say the third one the
archetype is the hippie right like the
very much in the body but in a body
consciousness like this idea that
everybody is connected and
and i would say in the same way that
those those three archetypes all have
their
beauty and the light side which is this
interconnectedness allows a degree of
there's a soft power in that the empathy
the empathic ability to connect to
others
the ability to hold your highest values
up because you understand the
connectedness but
but then there's the pathological
version too which is once again
perhaps you don't understand enough
about your own ego to see
what everybody has an ego and
and i would argue that i think the other
case to be made is perhaps it's not that
any one of those is a higher or lower
level it's just
knowing when that tool which one of
those
archetypes do you embody in a certain
moment based off
the necessary outcome the most high
outcome
right because i think that's the biggest
thing you see in the world right
is is folks that are speaking their
native language through one of those
three archetypes
but their message fails to resonate with
a broader audience because
they're too niched up on one of those
archetypes you know
it's very chameleon is what the optimal
would be
in that scenario you know but in granted
this is just one man's point of view and
and
i think this is maybe even fresh in my
mind too because this morning i went to
i went to uh this this um
this like group workout thing on the
beach in santa monica and
like i loved it and i and i will full
well admit like it's a little bit
it's a few inches or a few feet beyond
like
my comfort level in terms of
groundedness and that body thing
because i am my default is up here man
i'm more that first one than i am the
second one
but with time i've learned i've learned
some of the native language of that
second archetype
and it's it's useful because it opens up
a whole new audience that you can
interface with in a whole
new way a whole new language in which to
navigate the world but i you know it's
when you go in the most
extreme version of that that you get
smacked in the face and you think wow
this really is
my native tongue is not this but how can
i
integrate the the light side of it to
use almost your
um version you talk about this idea like
how do i keep the baby and get rid of
the
bath water that's that's what it is yeah
that is what it is in the sense it's
like
we shoot ourselves out to this
polarity of
being extremely embodied
and then we sort of parse out
the signal and we take that
with us into our costume closet
but we drain the dirty bath water of
noise the pathologies that we're
describing from the extreme
and we do the same thing with the hyper
scientific hyper analytical
hyper philosophical hyper brain oriented
because the rational gets drunk on its
own
brilliance you know yeah so similarly
we take parse out the signal take it add
it into the costume closet
drain the dirty bath water
and don't fall into the traps of
pathologizing there
and in a sense we become very much so
again it's super duper abrahamic because
it's
joseph in the code of many colors sure
it's it's the chameleon
and that sort of integration
of perspectives that integration
of
modalities of being
is what usually leads
someone to a more holistic
healthy prosperous well-being for
themselves
their family the community the world
yeah
and in this case sort of becoming more
able to take on
costumes place them into the closet
it enables
oneself to actually undergo said process
that we were
indicating at the beginning which is
creating that juxtaposition between
colored awareness and pre-coloration
awareness
and to work out the muscle to go closer
and closer towards pre-coloration wars
basically what happens is that
the as you work the muscle of
pre-coloration awareness
there is in a sense a moment
when it clicks when you
become in a sense realized
in the sense that you realize that
sentience or awareness or
consciousness itself is it
it is source it is god
the very beingness is it
that is it then once that's realized
then from
there
you harmonically
interweave with existence
at a more with all coloration
with awareness both pre-coloration
and colored so again that becomes a
unity but you
juxtapose them in order for you to
understand that self-realization
and then you unify them and you
create from that place of knowledge
which then makes everything that you do
from the highest level of morality
so that's sort of the synthesis of that
joseph in the code of many colors
chameleon that knows how to ed between
the analytic
and the feeling oriented that then gives
that synthetic perspective
more ability to self-realize
which then makes their
self-actualization
from the highest morality possible
word um word i love it
um that was good we got that done in
25 minutes yeah and then i think it's a
nice like setup
maybe and here's what i think we can do
is like take okay we've laid some
framework i think we've we've
narrowed in on what the kind of issue is
maybe what we do
do now is almost how do we embody it or
how do we talk about it in very
practical terms and
one of the things that came to my mind
man is is i i feel like i've kind of
articulated this point of view to people
in the past and
like the the pushback i usually get if
if somebody pushes back on it they it's
something along the lines of
well if you're operating that way isn't
that like inauthentic or isn't that
like how do you do that in a way that
you're not compromising
yourself you know the essence of
yourself like how can you be
because almost like i alluded to i think
everybody has a natural territory
like if we're just gonna make it and
this is definitely reductive but if
we're just using those three
triparte the triangle of those three
poles the the geek
the jock and the hippie like everybody
probably falls somewhere closer to one
of those three
and some people are very extreme on the
on the pulls of that but
if if one were to try to make the case
of why
you can why you can ebb and flow between
those and still not compromise your
identity and i think it's almost like
and maybe it is kind of sort of what you
were saying about
the coloration idea this idea that you
in order to come to that state where you
can ebb and flow between
rhetorical languages or states of being
you have to
super firm on your values because i
think the danger is if you're not
somebody who's really
gone inwardly or gone out really and and
nailed down like what are your personal
ten commandments like what what bars
will
you know what lines will you not pass
because you
are so convicted on those that this is i
know
that doing this is just wrong for myself
for the world for my friends for my
family
i think you have to be a really value
convicted person to be able to
move into that state of kind of this
more fluid identity because the danger
is
if you're not firm on your values you
what you you become this other person in
different scenarios
and you compromise your values when you
do it like you're not
you're not maintaining your fundamental
essence like um
and if the first core value
is truth yeah
what occurs is that the
the sentient agent the conscious agent
realizes that
first i must know
what is i
first and if that becomes the first
then the
simultaneity in pursuing the core value
of truth
resonates as we self-realize
and simultaneously another core
value of
self-actualization emerges from the
highest morality
of i express from that self-realized
non-duality i express as
the individual from a
creative place of business
entrepreneurship science engineering
politics art music
you pick yet
that core value comes simultaneously
with the core value of
truth of what
am i sure and so
that sort of synthesis there
can retain that authenticity that
we speak of yet
i would also like to say there is a
level of advanced
consciousness that is called a mirror
consciousness
sure which is in a sense beyond
the levels of being
in service to others in a very loving
way
where you've now mixed wisdom with that
which is another level of consciousness
which is now
love wisdom level consciousness where
you know how to create distance so that
you're not
always just giving love but that you
know
but you know how to take so important
back
and then the next level above that is
typically called this mirror
consciousness
which is sort of the joseph and the coat
of many colors
or the chameleon level consciousness
where you basically are a pure
mirror and we work our purity over time
it's not
you get jumped to the pure mirror
but if you imagine one of the visuals
that i'm currently developing is around
the way that the massive
solar farms work where they have their
reflective
mirrors that then reflect
the sunlight itself to the
tower that's in the middle which then
heats up with very high temperature
concentration that top part of the tower
which then powers an engine that then
creates electricity so
if your mirror
is dirty you're not going to reflect as
much light
yeah and there's a way to purify
that mirror and
it's the things that we've been
describing but as you purify that mirror
what happens is that
your ability to reflect
the light of being itself
of the one infinite creator itself
of us itself in our true
nature of infinity eternity love bliss
peace wisdom becomes
so high that
your presence in society
becomes so mirror
that where
whenever another individual
engages with you
they only experience the truth
of being itself and so
they only experience the truth of being
self so that infinity that eternity that
love
light bliss peace compassion
do you mean that in practical terms yes
give me an example
yeah so here's the example great
question here's the example
you're embodying literally in this body
and right now you are you you
are painting i think there's even
elements of this conversation that are
those three archetypes
embody this make this number two how is
this number and to me i'm already
all three at the same time where i'm
giving you this
perspective from a deeply embodied
perspective and
a deeply oceanic perspective and a
deeply analytic perspective
all at the same time in this example it
would be something along the lines of
and you can tell because the difference
is when
someone is all three they are from an
essence an energy like what i'm exuding
currently
the essence of being especially hyper
analytical
will typically look a little bit more
in some ways in some expressions of it
as though it is a little bit
faster paced and maybe a little bit
up in the head and it can be in shapiro
basically
the energy of ben shapiro is like the
most archetypical
heady analytical fire like machine gun
fire machine gun literally he's a verbal
analytical machine gun right it's
there's there's a reason why his his
go-to
line is facts don't care about your
feelings because he's so disembodied he
is so
doubling and tripling down on the
analytical yeah that's good
so let's let's continue the example
there's that was um
there was representation can i say one
last thing there was a reason why it was
so
think about the inherent humor of why
people thought it was so funny
that he was criticizing the song wap is
because wap was the epitome of the
tangible the embody the sensual the
sexual
and like the friction the obvious
friction between this hyper-analytical
character and
megan the stallion and um um for getting
the other
chick uh nicki minaj like those things
couldn't
the humor and the power and that was
just the extreme contrast between those
two ways of being
because they were like the almost hyper
archetypical analytical and bot and
bodied yeah
you know yeah right wow just an
observation
it's interesting that you pull that that
very
that example from the very
fabric of our collective consciousness
which is so resonant
and then here's another example from the
collective conscious that is so resonant
you gave the one with the two poles that
was very clear there which is really
cool
and then i'll give the one that's a
little bit more of a
very generic very everyday
so this is your sort of
presence when you are at a
let's say a grocery store
the bodega nice as evan has
taught me in los angeles
so in this case it's not your
chained corporate
grocery store it's your small
mom-and-pop family-owned
store in your local area
so it's literally where you've been
coming in maybe
once a week for a couple months and
you've even become
familiar with the family
that runs it so now
what the mirror consciousness does one
that is extremely
integrated with the nature of reality
the nature
of our true essence
they engage
with the cashier at
checkout and even before that
as maybe there is a question
example
i had some interest in wanting to get an
item
at the store that was not in stock
and so i very lovingly
said my brother is this item
do you guys by chance have it in stock
oh no we don't have that one in stock
right now
okay gotcha thanks for letting me know
you know
now there's a big sort of difference
between that loving compassionate
peaceful query about the item in the
store
versus one that is in a sense almost as
though
like demanding that yeah they be
have what i am currently interested in
and being frustrated by the fact that
it's
not there yeah and so
now you know when you're
at checkout
you know your level of resonance
with the person no matter what state
they are in and this is sort of another
very solid way to
to explain this i was thinking about
that as you were saying this perfect
perfect perfect timing then so it's
this is the david hawkins levels of
consciousness
very similar to claire graves don beck
and chris cowan spiral dynamics
or any of the greatest minds that have
sort of
catalogued the evolution of
human development from a more egoic
level to a more enlightened level
so now this is what the chameleon the
joseph and the code of many colors
the mirror level consciousness can do
it can from a level of pure truth
engage with any of these
levels and nice it can
it can do it from a
from basically taking its
achievement where it's at currently
which is a fully embodied self-realized
state of that
infinity eternity bliss piece
aka that enlightenment at the top of the
levels of consciousness and it basically
channels that through
very undergoing of
purification of their own vessel of
their own
mirror because they've cleaned the dirt
so that that solar light can reflect
off of it and
in doing so they when they engage with
let's say a
level of anger in this case
in the grocery store example that the
the card machine itself
is
taking a very long time to process
the payment usually it only takes 5-10
seconds maybe in this case it's taking
30 or 45 seconds and the person
expresses anger and frustration
at the fact that it's taking a long time
to do
that
that enlightened mirror consciousness
depending on
the scenario would potentially do
something like oh it's not a problem at
all brother
no problem at all we'll just be patient
as it processes or we'll figure out what
to do next with a smile
with that genuine loving compassionate
smile
and in doing so it basically
immediately in many ways and many times
extinguishes
the anger and it enables 100 yeah yeah
yeah you're my my brain is just like
cycling through a bunch of
related examples to this i mean another
one that's really much in the pop
culture
sphere right now is did you hear about
what happened with tom cruise and his
tirade
against the film set members that
weren't like social distancing do you
hear about this
ah i don't think so um so to summarize
it quickly
um so tom cruise is on the set of
mission impossible seven right now right
and um there's a whole staff and a crew
you know like there would be for a movie
and apparently they have very rigorous
uh coronavirus standards in place to
protect
all the members of the cast and crew and
um
for good re you know all for good reason
all completely
smart and understandable so what what
happened essentially is at
a moment during the filming um i guess
a couple the crew members got too close
to each other or sitting were kind of
hovering over a computer discussing
something
and tom cruise just verbally
you know blew up on these folks and kind
of you know cussed them out and said you
know
you know if i see this even one more
effing time like you
you're all out of here um and it's
really fascinating because well number
one
it was recorded so the whole world has
now heard it
it's precisely what he said and
precisely the way it was delivered but
i find it a fascinating case study in
human behavior to see the different way
people have reacted to it because a lot
of people
have heralded his reaction that that was
appropriate
that that was the right way it was
righteous in indignation almost this
kind of because there's this moral
element to the chrono
thing right that he was defending the
good even
this idea that the kind of the the means
justify the end that
even though he was very abrasive and and
and was not
looking to understand the intent or the
humanness of those individuals
he decided to react in a way that was
very in my opinion certainly very egoic
right
like i'm the arbiter of truth and reason
and i'm gonna
sh i'm going to very emphatically and
very aggressively
deliver what i think you need you must
do and it's
it's literally black and white there's
no there's none of this
reason there's no acceptance there's not
willingness there's not neutrality none
of these things in this list it's
everything that's below force it's very
forceful but
i think what's interesting about all
this is that
once again one man's point of view but
i think the mistake that a lot of people
neglect is that
they indulge
what will make them feel better about
the situation
versus what will actually deliver the
result
so even in even in and here's what he's
here's the even more interesting part
about it
even if you were thinking in a purely
selfish fashion even in a kind of an
unenlightened quote unquote if you will
a purely selfish fashion
and you kind of portrayed this idea that
you were
let's say that that scenario you just
said about the card
like what if the person was to
essentially do what you just said but
did it in a very disingenuous way like
in the back of their head
they were grinding their teeth and they
just wanted to they were
inches from just wanting to blow up on
this person but they made the conscious
decision to override that
and to do that but what if they did it
solely to step in the right direction
it was just definitely a step in the
right direction and i agree and what's
so interesting becomes more authentic
over time i and i i tend to agree with
that i think that's right yeah
it's it's more like the action happens
first and then this sentiment follows
almost
but i mean the bizarre thing about that
is there even if you were thinking a
very still in a very low level egoic
sense
that just being nice literally could
probably and
and end in more positive results down
the line that perhaps that person likes
you more now next time you go back
they help you cut the line or they throw
in a little bit extra
something or other or they totally they
they did there's some
that's how you get abundance when people
talk about manifesting
abundance they're usually talking about
when you
express from an enlightened state of
consciousness
what occurs is that you end up
manifesting
said scenarios where
somebody that is in serving the table
at the restaurant is so in love with
your energy
of your table is that that's when they
say that oh well
the kitchen had that extra appetizer
that's right and then you're like
no surprise um that's how it works
and if you're bad energy at the table
then the same
it's you're then it's the right the
other way
they're going to look for a reason to be
a little they they had your food ready
but they
let's just let their food sit there for
five minutes let it get a little colder
then we'll bring it out to that jerk
you know that kind of and that's real
that's so human and so
common right um this is a good
examples in the normal world in this tom
cruise example
the indulgence that you speak of
it is it is very in a sense
it's it's it's beautiful because it's an
expression of the creation that we get
to sit here and
and understand it and see it
and see how there's millions of people
around the world
reacting to it which is such a
fascinating phenomenon unfolding
and i think yeah the interest coming i
know what is more
efficacious now and so now we sort of
have
an integration of how all these
different people view
that scenario where tom cruise made that
expression and now their sort of
consciousness
able to reflect on how can we
be more integral how can we be more
holistic of more perspectives in that
scenario which
might be something along the lines of
well maybe these two
that are a little bit closer together at
that time
maybe first of all kind of like when
you're in when you're driving
and somebody cuts you off is to
think first and foremost maybe this
person is in a rush
to get to a hospital so that's usually
the first thing that comes to mind from
a more enlightened perspective
similarly with the the
two that are on the set it might be
something along the lines of
well these two might be
a little bit closer together because
they are looking at a model
that is only on a device that is
that they have to be in near proximity
to look at
and so then that's the first sort of
step towards what is called in the
schools of
enlightenment it's called creating the
pause
oh yeah you become more of an observer
or a witness
rather than something that's immediately
reacting
totally yeah and so when you create that
pause
it enables you to take in more of the
costumes
into your closet as yes joseph in the
code of many colors
and therefore you become closer and
closer to that
mirror state of being where
the way that to engage them is something
uh more like
hey guys i see that it looks like you're
currently really close together working
on something
i understand that you're probably doing
it because it's required
given the device and model that you're
looking at but let's
aim to see if maybe we can port that
content over to a larger screen so we
can stay a little bit further from each
other while we do it
yeah there's there are ways to very
and it's a very pretty yeah and
compassionately
and practically address scenarios like
this
and so these are the very
everyday scenarios and the very
celebrity influencer level scenarios
that end up
penetrating the collective conscious
which is
yeah which is really interesting that we
gave that
that sort of those examples along
this this path yeah of
yeah lungs consuming along this path of
of starting
with the
what am i question
and then that
core value of truth first and foremost
driving the muscle
more and more towards awareness
pre-coloration
which lands you more and more at the
truth
of sentience consciousness awareness
itself
being it source god
that in itself being that which then
enables
all of the self-actualization of your
next core
value of whatever
expression your unique artistic agent
would like to
create value into the world of it comes
from the highest
morality that would be i think
and feel and know
from my understanding as
the synthesis of this
conversation that we've had on the
episode are there other thoughts that
you'd like to share because we just
uh yeah 15 minutes that's good yeah that
was good we
were perfect timing yeah yeah cool
all right that's a wrap folks thanks for
thanks for joining us
on this conversation about
self-realization
and levels of consciousness and creation
expressing itself
we really appreciate you we would love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below on the episode let us know what
you're thinking
let us know what you're feeling let us
know what you're knowing and
understanding
about what we've been sharing definitely
what you're feeling i like that
did we get your blood flowing today did
we get that blood flow
you were aroused i mean were you aroused
i love it i love it
were you empowered were you do you feel
like going out and running a lap now
do you feel like meditating do you feel
like
yeah i don't know yeah you tell us yeah
you tell us in the comments below
i like that
like the video subscribe if you haven't
already share the video with people
that you know that this is important
for you can find
we have evans instagram in the
bio below you can go and follow him
there you can also
check out our links for simulation in
the bio below you can support us if you
would like and
help us continue actualizing our biggest
goals here
and support the other artists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders
scientists engineers
people that are building the future in
your communities and around the world
help them
manifest their goals undergo this
process that we've been talking about on
the episode
work the muscle self-realize truth is
the core value
we love you lots thanks for tuning in
we'll see you soon
peace